ils sont en première professionnelle
commerce lycée henri matisse de trappes
et il s'intéresse à l'art l'opération
mix art à l'école est un concours de
production artistique qui permet aux
élèves de collèges et de lycées de
s'exprimer sur des thèmes liés à la
diversité culturelle et à la citoyenneté
l'exarque bas c'est un projet dont
l'objectif est de responsabiliser et de
sensibiliser la jeune génération sur des
thèmes qui nous tiennent à coeur comme
la tolérance la diversité culturelle la
liberté d'expression la lutte contre le
racisme
ce genre de valeur l'association ariana
à l'initiative du projet propose aux
élèves pendant la phase de réalisation
de leur production des ateliers
rencontres avec les artistes du
collectif mix'art ces échanges riches
tant conseil en initiation et de
nouvelles techniques de travail sont
aussi des moments de partage important
pour les artistes
ça me donne énormément d'énergie c'est
un peu idiot à dire mais c'est comme ça
le contact avec les collégiens les
lycéens et sam est bénéfique et puis je
vois à chaque fois je suis surpris par
leur part leurs idées par leur niveau
technique parce que souvent à ces âges
là ils ont
on a beaucoup qui vont arriver avec des
a priori en disant voilà je sais pas
dessiner je sais pas dessiner et en fait
on se rend compte que s'ils se prennent
au jeu ils arrivent à faire des choses
très très belle place et anaïs et eloïse
ont choisi le thème de la tolérance et
symbolise leur amitié par l'association
des lettres à hisser pour amitié et
confiance la confiance de la base d'une
amitié
on a une liberté d'expression à l'issue
de ces ateliers les élèves éliront
quatre oeuvres représentant leurs
classes au concours académique qui se
tiendra fin mars
chaque académie récompensera alors dix
lauréats au cours d'une cérémonie
officielle
l'année 2013 marque le 50e anniversaire
du traité de l'elysée
et à cette occasion le concours mix'art
célèbre à sa façon la coopération franco
allemande
l'extension du projet aux échos
outre-rhin réunira le 5 juin prochain à
berlin
les grands gagnants pour la remise de
trophées